-Performing "The Greatest Gift"
from their new album,
"A Family Christmas,"
please welcome Andrea, Matteo,
and Virginia Bocelli.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Come and lay your head
upon my shoulder ♪
♪ Look outside the stars
are shining bright ♪
♪ Even though it's turned
a little colder ♪
♪ We can light a fire,
stay inside ♪
♪ Hear the angels sing ♪
♪ Hallelujah from above ♪
♪ Singing peace on earth ♪
♪ There'll be peace on earth ♪
♪ If we open up our hearts ♪
♪ And give a little love ♪
♪ -Uh-uh-uh-uh, uh-uh-uh-uh ♪
♪ The greatest gift is love ♪
[ Both ] ♪ Gather friends
and family 'round the table ♪
♪ Remember those we love
no longer here ♪
♪ Together take a moment
and be grateful ♪
♪ For the joy ♪
♪ For the tears ♪
♪ Hear the angels sing ♪
♪ Hallelujah from above ♪
♪ Singing peace on earth ♪
♪ There'll be peace on earth ♪
♪ -There will be peace ♪
♪ If we open up our hearts ♪
♪ -If we open up our hearts ♪
♪ And give a little love ♪
♪ -La, la, la, la, la, la ♪
♪ La, la, la, la, la, la, la ♪
♪ -And give a little love ♪
♪ -La, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la ♪
♪ La, la, la, la ♪
♪ -And give a little love ♪
[ Both ]
♪ -Hear the angels sing ♪
♪ Hear the angels sing ♪
♪ Hallelujah from above ♪
♪ -From above ♪
♪ Singing peace on earth ♪
♪ There'll be peace on earth ♪
♪ If we open up our hearts ♪
♪ -Open up our hearts ♪
♪ -The greatest gift is ♪
[ ALL ] ♪ -Looove ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.